thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 24th of
August I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
you have any pregosian the Wagner leader
has been killed in a plane crash along
with 10 other men on board reports
suggest that the plane was shot down
when entering Russian airspace what does
this mean for internal fighting in the
war in Ukraine Owen Matthews joins me on
the show
my colleagues that Lana mornets has been
in Ukraine investigating some first aid
delivery on the front line thousands of
troops are dying from wound sheep
reports when some could be safe with
proper medical equipment she joins me on
the show
it was the first Republican presidential
primary debate last night and its winner
wasn't even there in his cover story
this week Freddie gray says that Donald
Trump no longer needs the TV networks to
be the lead story he has his own
movement his own media and his own brand
Freddie and former Congressman Devin
Nunes now head of Trump's social media
platform true social join me later
here in the UK it may be recess but the
Tory party selections are well underway
the Tories have been picking local
candidates to stand in the coming
elections is this the best strategy
James heal and spectator contributor
Patrick o Flynn speak to spectator TV
and finally Disney princesses are for
many of us a fond memory of childhood
but how relevant are they to today's
children and as Snow White the latest
victim of the culture War Catherine D
joins me on the show
before we get going if you like
spectator TV do subscribe to our YouTube
channel specular TV is picking up
thousands of new subscribers every week
and you should be one of them just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
first up today's reports about the death
of Wagner Chief you have Getty progosian
may not come as a surprise to most in
fact some wonder how the man who Rebels
against Putin survived as long as he did
what does this attack tell us about
Putin's grip on power joining me now is
our Russia correspondent Owen Matthews
hi Ellen thanks for joining spectator TV
you say in your piece for coffee house
at yevgeny pregosian was a dead man
walking why was that
well uh for a very simple reason that um
if you defy someone as uh who are the
track record of murder and violence like
Vladimir Putin who's uh
um either directly or indirectly killed
so many of his opponents if you actually
come after a man like that uh in an
armed Insurrection I mean it's pretty
clear that those uh the stakes cannot
have been higher for him uh it's kind of
amazing
um that he survived the the precautions
survived the Mutiny uh it's amazing that
he was allowed to sort of walk the earth
especially the Russian Earth in the two
months intervening so in that sense uh
pregosian's death is probably like the
least surprising news story of the Year
from Putin's perspective Owen to what
extent did the Wagner Chief still
represent a threat or was killing
pregosians simply an act of Revenge for
the attempted coup several months back
um well I think both
um uh the threat part I think has
actually been more or less neutralized
insofar as that Wagner was partially the
Wagner troops that rebelled under
precautions orders back in June who have
been scattered some of them gone to
Belarus some of them gone to Africa uh
we don't know how many have joined up in
various uh regular Russian army units
like redut which is a Russian army unit
set up especially for former prisoners
uh so I don't think he uh Peter gaussian
was necessarily a military threat but
the fact that he was still at Liberty
was a sort of living proof of Putin's
weakness and uh in that sense the really
important question is you know how much
of his supporters uh are still out there
I mean there's been some chat on Pro
Wagner telegram groups saying you know
we will get revenge we've had a plan you
know for this eventuality you know watch
Kremlin we have no idea how serious
those are I think most people discount
the possibility of a second Wagner
Mutiny uh just Wagner but the bigger
question is uh what about all the
soldiers generals and you know officers
uh security service people bloggers who
supported pragodian and why did they
support precaution they supported
progression because pregosian they
thought was the only guy really fighting
a serious war in Ukraine while all the
rest were being incompetent and stealing
which is probably true
um and um
some kind of new head of this Hydra is
kind of going to be dangerous and
threatening to Putin going forward
because if the war doesn't go very well
there's going to be other people who
thought like precaution does did and we
can't exclude that they're going to
appear on the political scene at some
point in the future well that was my
next question to you does this death
leave an opening for somebody even more
frightening to come in
uh yes uh it certainly does
um the most dangerous opposition to
Putin is not uh liberals uh and anti-war
voices like Alexander Weil name the
opposition leader has been spent just
spent two years in jail
um that's not the dangerous opposition
the dangerous opposition
uh are the ultra nationalists and the
Hawks who argue that Putin is sort of
pussy-footing about and not doing enough
to prosecute the Ukraine war and they've
been the most vocal opponents of Putin
on the most vocal critics one of them is
prominent voices of the ultra
nationalists is a guy called
his real name is gibkin the former
Defense Minister minister of the
separatist
um danese People's Republic
and he's was jailed last month so that's
uh so that guy has been shut down but
there is a large we don't know how large
but definitely vocal
community of nationalists
um in Russia who actually uh have strong
ties and support in the armed forces we
know that
um so they're armed they're angry and
they are opposed to Putin so
um uh the last the last Showdown uh was
obviously the preggers Mutiny it failed
Putin won he survived precautions dead
Putin is not so you know that round goes
to Putin but I think the uh the big
takeaway for anyone
who has plans to challenge Putin from
the progression Mutiny is that
in a progressive Putin's word means
nothing Putin gave his word to Prego
that was the reason why he was in Russia
he just thought
uh thought that it was going to be
business as usual it was definitely not
business as usual
um he seems to be the only person in the
world that kind of considered Putin's
word to be good and Putin broke it so
the real takeaway is if you come with
the Tsar you better finish the job next
time around oh when you mentioned before
that pregosian's still walking around
Russia would have represented a symbol
of sorts for Putin of his own weakness
is that why we saw such a public
assassination Putin's regime has made us
very familiar with the concept of
accidental deaths but this was extremely
public was he trying to make a statement
yeah that's an excellent question I mean
there there is something and
deliberately performative about this
spectacular act of violence I mean he
wasn't just you know poisoned he wasn't
you know killed in a car crash pregorson
was literally blown out of the sky so
there's you know clear symbolism to that
um uh part of the symbolism is this was
apparently I mean we don't know quite
yet but I mean there have been witness
reports that suggest there were two
anti-aircraft missiles that down
precautions playing so it's like the
military killed precaution so that's a
symbolism
um he was killed you know violently in a
fireball along with uh many of the
senior members of the Wagner group
notably
formerly the commander and head of
Wagner group whose cool sign Wagner is
actually because he's an enthusiastic
Nazi uh you may have noticed that
actually
um late Putin Russia seems to share a
casting director with like the Lord of
the Rings because these people are like
incredibly terrifying looking uh Dimitri
woodkin literally looks like the king of
the Orcs And has swastika SS swastika
flashes tattooed on his collarbone as we
know also looks pretty scary
um but the uh all of these people were
traveling together all of the top Wagner
people they were killed in one what
military people call it decapitation
strike but of course it's quite telling
that the most successful decapitation
strikes that the Russian state is
currently carrying out are on its own
side
so what happens to the Wagner group now
Owen that has lost so many of its senior
officials
uh I think it's just going to be taken
over by greedy Uh Russian officers I
mean for many years Wagner has actually
been a kind of uh you know it's like
it's like passing go on a Monopoly board
a lot of top Russian commanders actually
were seconded spent six months in with
Wagner in Africa in Syria made a lot of
money that was how Wagner actually
became so influential among the senior
high command and in fact one of the top
commanders of Wagner was in fact
literally a former deputy defense
minister of the Russian Federation so
there's you know there were a lot of
people who have benefited from this cat
this cash cow now that um because Wagner
has been very busy
you know hoovering up uh you know gold
mines assets gas wells in all the
countries you know from Niger to um uh
Central African Republic to Libya to
Syria uh where it's had operations
um I think our business Empire is just
going to be absorbed by you know
vultures
um in terms of its uh continuing
existence as a threat to Putin um I mean
I don't think it's actually going to be
uh reconstituted in its old form it
can't be
um and that just leaves us a major Gap
in the sort of fighting uh in the line
of battle in Ukraine because uh
pregosian you know if all of his many
uh Legion faults
um was actually indeed one of the most
effective Battlefield commanders around
and
um one of the few Russian generals that
was actually able to deliver
some kind of Victory however
bloody and bloody it was but um that's
now gone so there's not no one else so
do so you do think that this
assassination will essentially have a
direct effect on Putin's war against
Ukraine
um uh the the effect already happened
after the Mutiny and when when when
Wagner was essentially sort of dispersed
and officially taken over by the Russian
state so if Wagner hasn't been in the
line of battle for some time not in
advance since the end of May
um uh it's not really the issue of uh
the Wagner fighting forces it's uh the
effect on the Russian war effort I think
is going to be more about you know how
is Putin going to
um uh where is Putin going to get his
Cannon Ford or from because Wagner was a
really important source of cannon fodder
they recruited as we know tens of
thousands of violent criminals including
murders and murder murderers and rapists
and offered them uh unconditional
discharge after six months of service
um and uh so you have a cannon for the
problem and you have a who to blame
problem because uh the arguments that
Putin the the precaution made and the
criticism he made of the Russian high
command all those things that he said
have not been addressed not being fixed
that the Army is corrupt it's
inefficient they don't know how to fight
the all of those things are true so if
the operation still continues to go
wrong or rather if they still you know
continue to lose bits and pieces of
ground to the ukrainians then Putin's
gonna have to come up with a new
narrative you know someone else to play
my last question to you on was something
interesting that stuck out in your piece
where you wrote that progressions
assassination could actually be
interpreted as a sign of weakness from
Vladimir Putin can you elaborate on that
will weakness insofar as
um in the sort of Mafia world mafia-like
world of the inner circle of Putin's
closest Associates what's most important
is personal trust they'll value loyalty
above everything
and part of that loyalty is giving your
word so let's just imagine for a second
this actually is literally a mafia
family you know the the boss has made a
deal with a discontented couple in a
lieutenant who's rebelled and been
forgiven and is you know has his guard
down and then you assassinate him while
his guard is down you've broken your
word what does that do to your
negotiating capabilities in future with
your other couples you know clearly what
you've done is you've just murdered a
man who trusted you so in that sense in
the terms of
um you know that the the what the
Russians called panyatta the
understandings not the laws but the
understandings that govern that sort of
world of the of the high Elite uh Putin
has actually just gone back on his word
and proved himself to be fundamentally
untrustworthy and I think that is
um if not necessarily a sign of weakness
um it's a sign of his um it's going to
weaken him in future I mean the weakness
is really that it fails it proves that
Russia is a failed state that has no
mechanism other than murder to punish
its wrongdoers that's really the sign of
weakness oh and thanks for joining
spectator TV
a great pleasure
next thousands of Ukrainian soldiers on
the front line are being wounded where
have the resources for first aid gone
Svetlana more nuts joins me now
hi spit Lana great to see you you're
still in Kiev
yes hi and I want to speak about your
article for the magazine this week but
before we get into that we've just heard
from Ellen Matthews about the death of
progosian and Svetlana I wanted to hear
from you with the Ukrainian reaction is
yes of course zelenski hasn't said
anything yet about what happened the
pre-washing but his advisor
said that Putin
he hinted that Putin was the one who
ordered the murder of prehushan and he
said that it will lead to even more
internal fighting in Russia and that
with this move putting his showing that
the next year during the elections uh
nobody can stand next to him that he is
the only one tar in Russia and nobody
can just try to march to Moscow and
overthrow it so uh he prefers right now
to use fear to all of his
people in his team and it can make
problems for him because
they will be afraid and that means they
will be less loyal to him so maybe they
will think about what can they do to
save their lives and to protect them and
maybe to
overthrow Putin but it's these are also
fantasies for Ukraine a bit because even
with pregosion was the only one who was
capable of doing that because he had an
army behind him he had Wagner
mercenaries and the weapons about two
months ago he lost his chance and maybe
if he walked up to the Kremlin he would
be heading Russia right now but he
didn't do that and he paid with his life
for that
sitlan I want to Pivot to your article
in the magazine this week where you
write about witnessing some of the
terrible injuries sustained by Ukrainian
troops on the edge of the danios region
can you tell me what you saw and under
what circumstances
I went to the edge of the domestic
region with the Ukrainian medical
interior Battalion called Hospital years
they were evacuating injured soldiers
who were handed to them by the combat
Medics and they their task was to keep
them alive till they bring them to the
hospital in nipro so the soldiers were
endured like ready for five hours when
we received them and we spent four hours
more to bring them to the hospital so it
is almost 10 hours long evacuation
and this is a very common case in
Ukraine right now
Svetlana why doesn't the rest of the
world know about the exact number of
Ukrainian casualties
a Ukraine doesn't say about its
casualties because they say it helps to
avoid the enemy knows about how how many
people Ukraine lost and build the plans
according to that so they say okay this
is a secret information we will disclose
it on only after the war ends but it
prevents
scrutiny because
as ukrainians don't know how many died
they don't know if the soldiers were
received all they needed when they were
injured and maybe some of them could
could have been saved you know because
when I talked to the medical staff who
work on the front who works on the front
line they said that many soldiers die
not because
uh not on the front line but they were
injured they died during the evacuation
because there was no evocation transport
there were no medical kids to help them
or their
components inside of those medical kids
were bad quality for example tourney
cats their devices to stop the bleeding
like often their Chinese ones and they
are very cheap but they come apart they
lose pressure and the soldier dies so
right now it is
a question are the injured soldiers
treated as well as they must be in
Ukraine right now and of course
Ukrainian government they are focused on
the counter or fancy I'm asking weapons
from their allies but
and the focus like swifted from the
soldiers when they are injured okay they
already made their task they fought in
the War and now they are not needed by
the state and it shouldn't be like that
Lana can you talk a little bit more
about the corruption in this area of
first aid provision
yes corruption has been always a problem
in Ukraine but during the last the last
weeks the news emerged about the member
of Ukrainian medical forces that he
supplied the Chinese
tourniquet of Love quality and they send
them to the front line and he also uh
said that they were NATO standards so he
sold he bought them from the company
owned by his daughter-in-law as inflated
prices
and right now it has been under
investigation and he has been fired but
these are 11 000 Chinese medical kids
were already sent to the soldiers so we
can just imagine uh if they were not
taken away these keys if the soldiers
didn't see there but quality and they
were unfortunately endured and they use
them you can imagine how many of them
died because of this case of the
corruption and it is not the only one
because for example last year in Viv
um medical kids supplied by American
volunteers just disappeared uh these
were ten thousand medical kids and they
could save the lives of ten thousand
soldiers but they disappeared maybe they
were later resolved I don't know this
and I know that the U.S is currently
investigating this case and these are
just only two examples of what is
happening and of course
I wouldn't like it to sound like all the
help Ukraine receives has been resolved
or Ukraine is just full of corruption
and nobody has the soldier but but
because it is not like that but
unfortunately we have these cases when
it really happens and because of that
our soldier died and right now when I
when I was traveling around the front
line I was talking to soldiers and they
were telling me that
Brigade
have not enough people to fight in so
because volunteers ended and the
conscription is going on but it is not
enough and Ukraine is losing lots of
people and it has less people than
Russia so every life matters not because
just only every life matters but because
Ukraine doesn't have many people to
fight and we don't know how long this
war is Gonna Last for and if if we have
the opportunity to have dangerous
soldiers and later if the injury is not
so heavy they can come back to the front
line we should do it it's it's not it's
not just because of course it's because
of the principles because we have to
take care of the people but it is also
about the worry for it so it is in the
interested interests of Ukrainian
government that the soldiers receive all
the medical kids and the transport that
they need to evocate them if they were
injured
speaking of Transport you also mentioned
in the piece that due to a lot of
bureaucracy that's severely limiting
transport at the moment that is
impacting how quickly soldiers can be
seen by medical professionals in such a
state of emergency surely that red tape
is not necessary
yes the problem is that the reforms that
they need needed to be made
um
the problem is that there are forms that
Ukraine needs to make in the peace time
they would take years to make because
the all these bureaucracy comes from the
Soviet era and Ukraine needs to change a
lot of laws and in a state of the war
it's very difficult to do all of that
and the Focus right now is on receiving
more weapons and fighting and liberating
the lands so but the problem is that
every occasion transport that Ukrainian
troops receive or every medical kid has
to be uh if it gets used or destroyed or
something happens it has to be written
off uh but it takes up to six six months
to do that because the official is
investigations must be carried on a lot
of paperwork is needed and imagine that
the soldiers are fighting they used a
medical kit they use the tourniquette
they stop the bleeding and then someone
hinted to spend two weeks to write off
the tourniquet and to say that it was a
stolen or something
their control over it is needed like to
say have they used the the cars how they
use the medical supplies but the process
of reporting it should be much faster
than it is right now because six months
of doing that is something
unimaginable and it's that's why the
medical the combat
Medics I talked to told me that they
prefer to take the help from volunteers
from ukrainians who donate money buy
them the cars for evacuation by medical
kids and to use them rather than use the
help from the government because they
help received from volunteers they do
need to write it off they just can use
it and keep going with the war you know
but the help from the government they
need
to make a lot of paperwork so they
prefer okay if you're not gonna take
this thing from the government and also
the problem that
Ukraine receives a lot of medical kids
from abroad and are allies unfortunately
don't always know what is what is better
to send and sometimes they think better
to buy a lot of Chinese tourniquets than
good American ones that are like 10
times more expensive they think okay
I've been buying more than we help most
of more soldiers but it doesn't work
like that because uh bad quality medical
kids they kill the soldiers
but okay it doesn't have any standards
and for checking those medical kits they
just send them the record they receive
them and send them directly to the front
line without any checks and when uh
senior Medics complain about the
equality cave is not allowed to complain
to allies because as you know the
landscale ready was caught a lot of
times ungrateful that we don't thank
enough our lies so Ukraine never
complains about what we are receiving
actually and it is not only about
medical cases also about cars sometimes
they arrive to Ukraine are completely
unusable and Ukraine has to uh
remake them completely so they work they
can actually work at the Frontline
Svetlana thanks for the update and
thanks for joining me on spectator TV
thank you
last night was the first Republican
presidential debate eight candidates
took to the stage and debated topics
like climate change and abortion but the
main topic of discussion was the
candidate who didn't show up take a look
but we are going to take a brief moment
and talk about the elephant not in the
room
has been indicted in four different
states on 91 counts he will be processed
tomorrow in Georgia at the Fulton County
jail for charges relating to the 2020
election loss you all signed a pledge to
support the eventual Republican nominee
if former president Trump is convicted
in a court of law would you still
support him as your party's Choice
please raise your hand if you would
just hold on
missing candidate Donald Trump was at
the same time speaking to broadcaster
Tucker Carlson on his show for acts
formerly known as Twitter where he gave
this reason for not appearing in the TV
debates take a look Mr President thanks
for joining us thank you why are you at
the Fox News debate tonight in Milwaukee
well you know a lot of people have been
asking me that and many people said you
shouldn't do them but you see the polls
have come out and I'm leading by 50 and
60 points
and you know some of them are at one and
zero and two
and I'm saying do I sit there for an
hour or two hours whatever it's going to
be and get harassed by people that
shouldn't even be running for president
should I be doing that and a network
that isn't particularly friendly to me
frankly you know they they were back in
Ronda sanctimonious like crazy and now
they've given up on him I mean he's it's
a lost cause
for the cover piece this week Freddie
gray takes a look at Trump's decision
not to appear in the TV debates his
argument in short is that Trump is the
story whether he appears or not joining
me now is Freddie gray and Devin Nunes
head of Trump's social media platform
truth social
Freddie write the cover for this week's
magazine about Trump Vision he's the
only show in town you say so much so
that he doesn't have to take part in the
National debate he's still present talk
us through your peace well I think what
happened in 2015 and particularly in the
uh Republican candidate debates in 2015
is that Trump sort of Set Fire to the
nomination process in many ways and
particularly the media side of it
because these debates admittedly they
don't draw in the same kind of numbers
as the big final two Showdown
presidential one just before the
election
um but they were always considered very
important and sort of starting blocks
for candidates to to lay out their stall
to say who they were and more
importantly to some pay fealty to the
huge TV networks and that would then
honor that field see by projecting them
into the national Consciousness Trump in
2015 took over the national to some
extent the global Consciousness uh and
certainly with the media
um this year this year something similar
but different is happening
um in that he is now shunning the
networks to some extent the TV debates
is not going to do them
um and it doesn't really seem to matter
um because the power relationship has
changed uh and the power of news TV has
changed because to some extent the
Trump's story is the story of how the
media
misunderstood their role in politics and
thought that they could stop this
political phenomenon and they couldn't
and now and as we approach 2024
um we're seeing just quite clearly how
little they matter
Devin Freddie writes in his piece that
he wasn't surprised that Donald Trump
decided not to take part in these
debates were you surprised and do you
think this changes the game for
presidential elections in the future
well for those of us who have followed
politics closely here in America for a
long time it didn't make any sense for
president Trump to participate in the
debates
and the main reason why is is that we
haven't really been here as a country
meaning the United States where you have
a president who left office who still
claimed his title as the Republican
party leader and even though I think
that some of the Republicans in the
Beltway the lobbyists and the Wall
Street people they don't like that but
the facts are the facts and that is that
President Trump has built the biggest
political movement in modern American
history Bar None uh there there is no
there is no doubt of that and plus what
you won't hear the Republican Party
leaders say is that they had to have
President Trump in the last election
cycle because without them they couldn't
raise any money on their own because
what president Trump did is he bypassed
his Freddie I think you know eloquently
puts in his peace he bypassed all the
Norms went straight to the American
people and developed what the Democrats
had been working on for years which is
small dollars millions of them all over
the country
and so you know with that uh in in with
President Trump fighting the election
results with him staying out there on
the campaign trail with him out there
doing rallies it's impossible you know
as a guy who served you know two decades
in Congress you know I may be proud I'm
elected and I may be the the leader of
of a committee or the leader of the
Senate but guess what if you don't have
the people and you can't raise the money
you're basically a leader without any
followers president Trump is a leader
with more followers than any political
player in modern history so therefore
why would you put yourself in a position
where you've got you know half the
candidates you know that are up there
are not I don't mean this in a bad way
but they're you know they have every
right to run but they're not serious
candidates they have no chance to win
and if president matter of fact I'm not
sure that any of the candidates that are
that are out there today if president
Trump was just to say hey see you guys
later I'm gonna go play golf in Florida
have fun with your politics
my guess is that none of those
candidates would ultimately be the
Republican nominee so when you have the
votes sewed up there is no reason to
entertain
um you know kind of the chaotic uh
wannabe people that most likely would
not be the nominee anyway if president
Trump wasn't there speaking of followers
uh of course irrepresenting truth social
and I'm interested in your views on the
influence on of social media at the
moment compared to say those mainstream
television shows and indeed the debates
Donald Trump is talking about spending
time on X the new version of Twitter
um he's talking about going to True
social where he says he's going to make
his case instead of doing these TV
debates
um and I think it's interesting that
he's decided to almost pit them against
each other and it does reflect in some
ways I suppose how people consume their
news now
yeah and if you if you look at it
um the landscape has just changed from
2016. and it and it evolved rapidly
after that 16 election so president
Trump successfully used
the social media specifically Facebook
really was the main was the main one of
course he would put his he would put his
message out on Twitter back in 16.
but really he was using Facebook because
he was live streaming his rallies
and at that time you have to remember in
16 there was on the conservative center
right there was essentially Fox News
Rush Limbaugh Mark Levin Sean Hannity
4-5 of the talk radio hosts and then
there were Regional talk radio hosts and
some uh you know some of the
center-right magazines that sort of
thing but it was maybe 10 or 15 Majors
that you had to deal with well in 16
president Trump went around all that
because he was going to Twitter and
going on Facebook live streaming his
rallies and a candidate with really not
very much money beat the
the the most favored candidate in U.S
history by the mainstream by using
social media
now what happened after you know 2016
outside of Obama destroying our justice
system and putting a a president under
investigation by the Obama justice
department intelligence agencies outside
of that in 2016 shortly after the
election a lot of people forget this but
the term fake news a lot of people think
Donald Trump made up that term fake news
actually the two prominent players to
mention fake news well before Donald
Trump were two gentlemen you guys have
probably know one was a guy named Barack
Obama right after the election that said
it was fake news on the internet that
allowed Donald Trump to win
Anna was the guy by the name of Mark
Zuckerberg who then in 2020 decided to
spend nearly 500 million dollars of his
own money
so what happened since since that time
period of fake news well one thing
Donald Trump took that phrase hoisted it
back on the fake news and now you got 70
80 percent of Americans who don't
believe any of the news as they as and I
agree they shouldn't because they're
either they either are fake because
they're coming from their own by a
billionaire who has an agenda multiple
billionaires
um or they're a publicly financed
company I mean a a government funded
which means they're they got to be woke
to get their government funding and then
you just have a small handful center
right maybe less than five percent that
tries to get the real story out Fred I
want to pick up on this question of what
constitutes fake news and also what
constitutes fake allegations and you
address some of this in your piece you
talk about russiagate and you say that
for a lot of Americans on the right but
not necessarily on the right they watch
what happened around those allegations
which were proven essentially false then
Trump was somehow working with Vladimir
Putin in order to break the 2016
election and now they see all these
other accusations and regardless of
elements of truth that may well be
behind them they're simply not listening
they've decided to lump all of what they
consider to be fake news together
um now this works to Donald Trump's
Advantage as he's facing many of those
allegations arculate also gives him an
argument to avoid serious scrutiny
because uh the the allegations go well
for years he had these questions put to
him which you know in retrospect looks
silly now if anyone wants to put serious
questions to him they're also going to
be considered silly whether that's right
or wrong however I think is is is very
much Up For Debate and the fact that he
isn't showing up to these debates and
the fact that he isn't going to be
scrutinized in that way
um maybe that won't sit quite right with
Republican voters I mean a lot of
primary voters the majority certainly do
wish he was showing up yes I mean the
vast majority do want to him to go to
the debates I think 73 according to one
all of trump supporters want him to be
at the debate but that's for the very
simple reason that they want to watch
Trump Vision they want to watch the
Trump show and without him it's quite
boring on the legal side uh just to
become what Devin said I think he's
right to point out that um you know the
Democrats were talking about fake news
before uh the Trump piss and the Trump
gang did but I think it was kellyanne
Conway Devin Maybe I'm Wrong in saying
this that really sort of projected the
term into the national Consciousness
when she started talking about it
um but as for the uh the the legal side
I think at the moment obviously it is
helping him in the polls it's boosted
him in the polls there is a concern even
among people
um who were close to Trump diving
because it's those of trump then uh then
a lot of people so he can probably uh
tell us
um but there is concern about the
Practical effect it's going to have on
his campaign uh I mean this is an
enormous amount of work that he will
have to get through as the criminal
defendant he will have to get through it
uh while running a presidential campaign
can he do that I think already you're
seeing uh Trump and the people around
him uh building this as part of their
Victory narrative that you know he
people like to emphasize his you know
superhuman energy levels and he does
seem to have extraordinary energy levels
particularly for a 77 year old man
and you can see that this will be the
contrast will be between frail dodgery
old Joe Biden and Trump facing this
astronomical challenge of running for
the presidency probably the most
stressful thing any human being can do
on top of nearly 100 criminal charges uh
on top of facing nearly 100 criminal
charges uh and that will that will be
the story I think which will be look at
what he's getting through and he's still
doing it and that's assuming he can
still do it because it is an
extraordinary amount of work to have to
get through
Devin can you give us some insight into
what the president's thinking uh 2024 is
going to look like well look uh I think
he the main thing that he wanted to make
sure I think when I was in London last
year when we when we launched true
social that was the number one question
that I kept getting was well is is Trump
going to run
and you know he was he was very
transparent he said look I want to make
sure that I'm in good health
and he is in amazing Health as Freddie
said I mean he just goes and goes and
goes works all day seven days a week uh
till late hours of the evening early in
the morning and you know that I think it
resonates you know with the American
people
um and you got to remember as much as
the uh fake news and the left have tried
to uh kind of place over Trump you know
continually and it's the most ridiculous
thing and I think it's what they all
Miss is that they they love to say
things like well uh it's just a
personality they're just following the
the individual
well what they forget is they forget
that Donald Trump is rooted in something
that goes back for decades that is a
very near and dear to him and from the
first time that I actually met him and
spent time with him when he was
campaigning out in California I I
recognized it and that is that he is a
man who pays close attention to big
buildings big factories and he loves
those things that's what he grew up with
that he built them he loved he loved
that
and what's been bothering him and you
can go back and watch interviews that he
did from the late 70s I think is the
earliest one that I've seen all the way
through
he can't stand empty factories anywhere
in the United States and he can't stand
to see all of these products coming in
from Asia
and that is why he ran and he believes
that to his core so when he says things
like America First people's oh that's
just a slogan oh really who else was
talking about this and I'll tell you
with somebody who who was in in
Washington dealt with many of these
trade agreements every president
Republican and Democrat and I served
under I guess what three different three
different ones
um they all said and in every Republican
candidate and every Democratic candidate
they all said the same you know
ridiculous thing that was we're gonna
get tough on China we're really going to
get tough we're going to take it
seriously when I get in there we're
gonna we're gonna stop this unfair trade
imbalance with China guess what none of
them did a damn thing about it when
Trump got in he had said the same thing
that all the other Republican candidates
did and most of us in Washington time
said oh yeah well that's you know that's
never going to happen he's never going
to change that and I'll be damned if he
didn't do it
and so that and that was fighting
Republicans and Democrats
and he said look we're slapping on
tariffs on China he's also you gotta you
know nobody everybody forgets this he
was against the Iraq War from the very
beginning and look a lot of us who were
there at the time we think that we were
lettuce gray we were lied to uh I mean
in the United States and officials that
were in there
um you know you can and it's easy
playing Monday Morning Quarterback but
one thing we we know is that the United
States military can't be turned into a
woke nation-building type of force it
doesn't work
and if you look the way that we exercise
the war on terror uh it was not done
properly and president Trump said that
for many many years so he's a man with
very passionate positions that resonate
with the American people that the fake
news just says oh it's a personality
well the more they say that and they're
the ones who weaponize the justice
system when President Trump could have
easily went in there and said
we're going to prosecute prosecute
Hillary Clinton
and he said look let by gods be bygones
let's just get to governing and look I
bet if he had that to take back he would
have taken that back knowing now it's
easy looking back knowing just how
corrupt our justice system is and our
intelligence agencies in the United
States Devin I suspect a lot of people
who like and dislike Donald Donald Trump
would agree with you that he's very
passionate about a lot of issues my
suspicion is that his views on the Iraq
War from decades ago now uh will
probably not be what influences the
results of the 2024 campaign and when we
look at his popularity when we look at
that personality which you're saying
um is is the wrong emphasis coming from
mainstream media it does seem to be the
case when we look at polling figures
that Donald Trump's still quite
unpopular certainly he's popular as the
Republican Grassroots right now but the
latest pupil says that 63 percent of the
American people find him not so popular
and if we look back on the previous
elections 2016 some of those points
you're talking about jobs energy G he
won the election on albeit by really
small margin across three cities but he
did win the election on in 2020 he lost
in 2022 many of his candidates lost when
you look at poll figures like that 63
percent even going up against someone
like Joe Biden who isn't very popular
himself
are you so convinced that that
personality really doesn't matter based
on previous performance in several
elections and we're not Republican
Grassroots but your average American
voter sits now
look it all comes down to where have we
come you know since 2016.
and and well really going back to 2000 I
mean the elections have been very very
close since 2000. I think where you see
a lot of that polling you're going to
have the the left and the right or is
the left is now very extreme it's a
socialist party it's not the old
Democratic left uh and then you're gonna
have this fight as long as you have kind
of never Trump Republicans out there
um you're going to see Donald Trump and
he's gonna you know he will it'll always
be tough for him to get much over 50
percent in terms of favorability
um this is not what it was when Ronald
Reagan you know or George W bush who I
think were probably the last two
Republicans to have a little bit of the
time you know above 55 percent
favorability but you know we haven't had
a republican in a long time uh be it at
a high favorability
um but I'd rather I feel strongly as I
think a lot of the Trump supporters do
that we should go with the person that
we know is going to actually do what he
says
Freddie what do you make of that Devin
mentioned before he's not convinced that
any of the candidates in these who are
taking part in these debates uh stand a
chance at winning
um the nomination you write in your
piece as well that you're quite
skeptical about whether or not these
debates can gain traction without Donald
Trump the risk however is that you do
have people in those debates who have
been two-term Governors who are
currently governor who have served in
the Senate who have been elected
politicians a lot longer than Donald
Trump were and will have some records to
boast about and may also point out areas
where Trump wasn't as successful say he
pledged to build a wall there isn't a
wall uh you know and we can go on and on
about certain things that were said is
there any opportunity for one of these
candidates let's even say through a
social media clip from the debate to
have some kind of cut through I mean of
course there is you know there's 11
months to go till the Republican
National Convention there's a whole
primary cycle to get through uh
obviously the old t-shirt week is a long
time politics this is a long time to go
through so it would be be idiotic to say
that the the primaries are done and
dusted
um but they are done and dusted
at the moment we are heading uh towards
a coronation uh not a contest but to
speak to Devon's point about uh Biden
and favorability I think he's quite
right I mean the the kind of you
mentioned the pupil but the kind of real
clear average of polls suggests that
tide is on 54. that's not a huge margin
to work with and other polls that ask
people of all independence and so on
that ask people was the country better
on the Trump a lot of people are saying
yes and so if you have that behind you
as a candidate that's a very very
powerful argument Freddie last point you
have a great line in your piece where
you say that Trump has destroyed all
pretense that television and news was
distinct from Show Business and I gotta
say I read that and it kind of summed
the whole thing up to me like many many
years of summing up right there Donald
Trump is rude he's arrogant he shocks
but a lot of people like it well exactly
I think what happened in 2015 and I'm
this is not a very original point is
that Trump uh showed that the media had
become uh sorry the news media had
become a bit of a joke and it's
interesting and if you look at the
decade beforehand that two of the big
success stories of American news media
were Fox News aimed squarely at
conservative viewers and it did
extremely well and rightly so
but the other one was John Stewart's
Daily Show which was one of the most
popular news shows in America throughout
the 2000s and that was a satire about
how ridiculous the news is and so by the
time Trump came along news was a joke
and he just sort of combined both he
combined both yeah he made people not
and I think people always underestimate
that about Trump is the extent to which
he makes people laugh and it's not
necessarily A laughter of endorsement or
support or hostility it's just a
fascinating thing to watch
Freddie and Evan thanks for joining me
hello and welcome to Roomba balls where
I Katie will speak to today's
Trailblazers
next political parties are gearing up
for a general election next year should
the Tories be selecting rise in
Westminster stars or Local Heroes James
Hill Covered this for his politics
column this week in the magazine and he
joins me now alongside former MEP and
spectator writer Patrick o'flynn
James you write the politics column this
week for the magazine and you say that
the conservatives are embracing local
candidates in the selection process
overestablished Westminster types and
there seems to be a lot of appeal this
idea that the local candidate will
represent local people but like any
choice they're usually trade-offs talk
us through it yeah so there's probably a
wider Trend really and it always goes
back to sort of the 1960s where
previously MPS were expected to kind of
be you know the parliamentarian great
legislators Etc and then since then over
the sort of past five six decades we've
seen more and more demands upon MPS do
not just live in their constituencies
but also to really take up all their
time with casework due to a variety of
different factors and influences and as
a result of that we've now seen a lot of
constituents really wanting to have
someone who is going to be a local
Champion is what the people describe it
as and they think that the associations
find it easier to sell a candidate on
the doorstep quite a cynical age if at
least they're from the area they know
the types Etc so in 2017 I think about a
one in three candidates three candidates
at the election were formal current
councilors and now that's kind of
doubled to about two-thirds of all
selections are going on so there's a
huge amount where you know once upon a
time it's very fashionable to be a spad
and now it seems you're more likely to
get selected as a council leader than
you are as a special advisor so will
this be a tactical consideration for
people going for certain seeds and it
sounds like that's becoming harder and
harder if you are a Westminster
candidate so to speak I do think so I
think it's notable that most of the kind
of Westminster types have actually had
some kind of familial
um or sort of geographical connection
it's a bit like an American presidential
contest where they'll say that these
sort of key swing States they have some
election you know relation in
Pennsylvania or they're from you know
somewhere like Nevada Etc and I think
really that's going to be a key thing
where those connections really matter
and that's not just because of the
attractions of local candidates but it's
also become the fortifications to
Outsiders that got really harder so it's
hard to go along to a selection meeting
pitch up have a week to try and charm
the association of members there when
you're up against someone who's known
the area and worked it really for sort
of five ten years or so and that's one
of the kind of key factors which is why
locals are winning out here
Patrick you were of course familiar with
the MEP selection process but what do
you think of the system overall does it
work well and how do you strike the
right balance between Westminster
politics and local issues when you have
the selection process well I think there
is undoubtedly from the Grassroots from
the general public a preference now for
local candidates and it's probably
someone in all the party machines has
done the maths and worked out that
there's a small but potentially
meaningful uh extra vote in in real
local routes and not just you know my
on-call worked in the factory up the
road in in 1983 sort of thing but actual
uh provable uh deep local routes um now
I kind of slightly bemoan that and it's
funny James mentions the the parachuting
Spades thing as the old way of doing it
but you know some of us just about
remember the idea of the great figures
you know and you think back to the
Wilson and Callahan cabinet for example
in the in the labor years and and all
the big figures around the cabinet table
and you know the idea of those sort of
people the Dennis Healey's Tony Benn
being super councilors and seeing their
role as there and and indeed their
opposite number the Nigel Lawson's uh
Thatcher herself being seen as having to
get to that level by being super
counselors rather than people thinking
seriously about the future of the
country uh I think that's the trade-off
I think the individual parties are
probably right it's worth a little
premium if you're in the Tory's shoes
this time you're fighting a defensive
election probably you're hanging on to
seats where the incumbent MP may have
ducked out and and you need to to
reassure the voters that you know we
care about your community so I can see
why it's happening I think as an overall
trend in politics uh it leaves something
to be desired you wonder where the next
generation of leadership caliber people
will come for from and Patrick now that
it is recess and compared to previous
years it's extremely calm do you think
people are starting to think seriously
about the next election and what that
looks like the selection process is of
course part of that but more widely
speaking around public policy too yeah I
think that conservatives uh are in this
strange space where almost every MP
realizes apart from a tiny handful of
kind of old Boris nostalgists apart from
them almost everyone realizes that to
try and change again or to destabilize
what she soon act would just look like a
massive Indulgence and it's soon act for
the election but I think under the
surface there's a lot of thinking a lot
of scrambling around a lot of people
maneuvering themselves into position and
I think the the the the who who after
Rishi question is looming because you
know however months we are in about
eight months nine months into a Rishi
Premiership you'd be hard to press to
Define sunachism and it is it a sort of
Center technocratic thing that's not
that far away from how Kirsten will be
prime minister and I think if the
conservatives are out of power
immediately after the next election
there will be a big conversation in the
conservatives about what do we stand for
I think Patrick's analysis is really
spot on I think the bigger question
comes what does the future party look
like what seats does conservatives can
hold on to if the whole red wall goes
blue that's one scenario are they going
to lose those seats perhaps which were
lib Dem up until 2015 and then voted to
a quite the brexity and quite Euro
skeptic tradition would they go um live
demon again and how many seats are there
was going to take them off from the
southeast Etc and what kind of electoral
Coalition can they conservatives really
form and this is all really interesting
in the kind of context of candidate
selections as well because I think the
conservatives over the past four years
have really suffered because they don't
really know which way they're supposed
to go do they lean to realignment do
they carry on with rubble issues is it
about migration would those alienate
those voters in the southeast of England
where a lot of the cabinet come from for
instance and all the lib dams are really
putting a challenge there so I think it
affects everything really because
whoever surprises your vote your vote
your your members of parliament is going
to really um I think dictate the
priorities you choose to articulate in
opposition and in government
James you write in your column that
Rishi c-neck is not anywhere near as
directly involved in candidate selection
as say former Prime Minister David
Cameron was with his A-list which
actually led to another former prime
minister Liz truss but is there another
side to this might the government be
looking at which candidates are being
selected by the Grassroots looking on
the issues and Pla looking at the issues
and platforms that they're standing on
seeing what gets some excitement and
then crafting their own Manifesto around
it I think the key difference there
between David Cameron and now is
government and opposition opposition
leaders have typically attracted the
Acclaim of the press and to the public
by changing their party and then saying
we've changed the party now we can
change the country so new labor New
Britain is something kirstan was trying
to do now by saying look I got rid of
you know the corbinites and some of the
less appealing parts of the party I can
now show that I can be decisive leader
in government as well simple fact is up
to 13 years of government and
particularly exhausting last few years
of government I think the Grassroots has
withered to an extent it's been allowed
to attract
associations but also Richie sunac as
well I don't think partly because of his
nature is as Patrick said more
interested in kind of governing than I
think pure politics and I think the
politics and scheming of say reshuffles
that are not necessarily the ones that
he would perhaps be uh always play to
his strengths so I think that in terms
of what the Grassroots offer I don't
think there's much of a kind of feedback
mechanism necessarily I think that
currently ever mostly As distracted by
what's going on in government and really
fighting the sort of national issues the
National Air warping things like that
the cchq involved in rather than kind of
15 years ago where they were really
involved in things such as the this
trust selection you mentioned in Norfolk
which was the turn of Taliban episodes
and they were very hair involved in that
Patrick James writes in his column that
while some people are thrilled by the
idea of a local Takeover in these
candidate selections other people are
about are more nervous about
diversifying skill sets diversifying
experience they feel that the Tory party
these people coming from all different
walks of life uh does that concern you
as well
uh not really I mean I think that's a
perennial sort of uh soft power struggle
between the different wings of the party
and they'll frame in there in their own
way and I you know
perhaps uh there might be a feeling that
that the center right might get more
people in in the slots this time
personally uh I'd be glad of that and uh
perhaps that the sort of parachuted
spads tend to be from the in the Tory
party the sort of more Cameroon uh type
people but you know for instance I I
look to the recent London mayoral
selection uh where of the the
london-based uh Metropolitan Tory party
had a series of kind of uh wish kids
they expected to contest the candidacy
who all self-immolated in the campaign
and they ended up with a proper
conservative uh by mistake in Susan Hall
who has sort of outer London Vibe about
her
um I think uh that actually could go
down very well with the election in
London and Susan Hall as that kind of
outer London Beyond Zone 2 Canada has
got that kind of local appeal and Taps
into something cultural if the
conservances produce a few dozen Susan
halls in provincial seats I think
there'll be people in London in the
conservative party who are fretting
about that but I actually think on the
ground it could appeal very much to some
of the the new Tory Coalition that
they've they've rather careless about
preserving but James you mentioned in
your column that one quite important
group that isn't being selected as
voters lean towards more local
candidates is women is that going to be
a problem I think so in the context of
you know for most of the past 70 years
since World War II the conservatives
consistently did better among Women
Voters than men voters and that's been
reversed in the past five six years or
so and what we've seen from the
selections thus far is about 20 I think
20 or so the candidates 25 have been
women which is about less than the
proportion they have in Parliament and
it's supposedly a name of the
conservative to try to get more women in
I think look the conservatives always
sort of disdained things like all women
shortlists they want to talk about being
selected their merits I completely
understand that but I think the problem
is if you select every you on the basis
of geographical diversity and say
everyone's local that can you know
produce one sense of diversity of having
voices from across the country equally
it means you could get issues where you
know partly about gender and
interestingly I think you're twice as
twice as many ethnic minority candidates
have been selected as female candidates
which is an interesting it's not I don't
think it's about sort of grassroot
prejudices Etc but there are there can
be overall in patterns if they're
represented locally and some issues
there and also career backgrounds as
well I mean you've got jobs for instance
like Lord Chancellor job meant to be a
top lawyer Phil I referenced in the
column one anecdote about Top London
lawyer who wants to go for a selection
but was told they'd have a minimum level
of candidacy requirements and they've
got a very demanding job lots of hours
and you know it those things can put
pressure I mean that there are some
concerns in Westminster among the party
Elite they wouldn't actually Express
these publicly most of the time there is
some concern that they're not going to
have the leaders of tomorrow that they
need if the conservatives are going to
become a vibrant Force the 2020s and
2030s well indeed Patrick when you've
written recently about the future of the
Tory party and its philosophical ideas
you have suggested that people like
Kimmy badnock and Penny Morton and
swella Braverman these women are going
to put a big stamp on the party in their
own way it is that reminder that the
selections that are being made now will
impact who becomes a future leader and
and you know who becomes the the big
voices in the Tory party in 10 15 years
time well absolutely I think after a
defeat we can see with what's happened
to labor after defeat a party tends to
to go for someone they ideologically
admire I mean in Labor's case you had Ed
Miller Band and then you had Jeremy
corbyn now obviously the difference is
the Tory selection and election
procedure for a leader gives MPS
something of a choke hold on on who gets
put in front of the members so I think
we can expect you know one sort of a
Centrist and one center right candidate
to go through looking at it from here it
would look to me like it'll be uh Cami
bade knock against Penny Morton is the
most likely thing I think it all depends
on really which MPS are going to be
there not just geographically and
ideologically but also what's the scale
of defeat if it is a defeat uh sort of I
think a 280 seat party looks very
different from the 230 or 180c and
depends if they're thinking it's just
going to be a two-term opposition or a
one term it's a one term in which the
student government is then think it
actually did quite well as a result you
can more likely to get someone like
James cleverley conversely I think it
could be a more radical Direction uh
departure from the direction of the
leadership if it's a pretty bad result
James and Patrick thanks for joining me
and finally following comments made by
the actors in the upcoming remake of
Snow White who was branded The Original
Stories Prince as a stalker many are
starting to wonder if Disney has been
carried away with the culture wars
journalist Catherine D joins me on the
show
Catherine I don't know about you but as
a kid I love the Disney Princesses but
it's very popular now to make feminist
critiques of these characters I remember
going to see the live-action version of
Beauty and the Beast which I was kind of
nervous about because Beauty and the
Beast is easily my favorite Disney film
and I was pleasantly surprised and I
thought they really brought out the
already existing undertones of feminism
in Beauty and the Beast and a few
moments were quite explicit but overall
that plot line remained pretty intact it
does seem like plot lines and new
characters being added is becoming a
popular thing to do with these newer
Disney remakes however and I wonder if
you think there's pressure coming from
the public coming from former Disney
Watchers you know when they were kids
grown-ups now to make those changes or
if it's not coming from them where is it
coming from yeah I mean I think a big
part of it is like
um fandoms so like the the people who
are like really like the hardcore fans
Disney adults
um you know the marketing marketing
teams will send people out and sort of
like these online communities and
they're they're much more Progressive
um than and much more left-leaning than
a general audience right so like it's
very popular to see these types of
reimaginings reflected in fan art and
fan fiction and I think the idea is like
they want to appeal to like the hardcore
like Disney gen Z fan
um but it's sort of myopic because
um probably the nostalgic Millennial fan
would be more likely to to actually go
to a theater uh right so I I think it's
it's like just completely botched uh
marketing marketing attempts this is all
in the news again because an actress
named Rachel Ziegler who plays Snow
White in next year's Disney release has
made some comments to the Press which
were quite controversial we're going to
listen to them now the original cartoon
came out in 1937 and very evidently so
um there is a big focus on her love
story
um with a guy who literally stalks her
we weird weird she's not gonna be
dreaming about true love she's dreaming
about becoming the leader she knows she
can be so Ziegler's Snow White is not
dreaming about true love she actually
Brands the prince a stalker but she's
dreaming of the leader she knows she can
be what do you make of these comments
um well she's definitely she's probably
a Zoomer right
um
I mean I I thought the comments were
like very annoying right like she's not
she obviously it is sort of like an
obnoxious character but I thought maybe
like the the reaction to it was was
really was even more interesting like
the dialogue that it created was more
interesting than her sort of uh like you
know off-handed or like kind of smug
commentary well there has been a lot of
backlash to her comments do you think
this is the Tipping Point for Disney do
you think they might realize that it's
gone too far I mean we no one's seen the
new Snow White it's not out till 2024 so
we have to make assumptions about what
might be in it but her comments to the
Press do suggest that they have
completely overthrown the the storyline
of Snow White
um and and perhaps actually people were
Keen to see something that resembled the
original
yeah I mean I think people get excited
to see
um like these these sort of shot by shot
remakes tend to do very well like you
mentioned
um Beauty and the Beast but you know my
my problem with these live-action
reimaginings
um is that they feel very sort of like
factory made right there's no like
there's just no passion in them right
and then on top of it they're completely
unrecognizable it's the the political
message is like very hamfested
um I you know it's unclear to me why
there hasn't been a Tipping Point
already because people just aren't like
audiences just aren't enjoying these new
these new films right like there's no
there's no appeal to them as far as like
Ziegler's comments being some sort of uh
Tipping Point maybe
um especially because it feels like she
herself somehow has like created this
cottage industry of like Angry 30 signs
like I was looking I was looking through
tip talk when this just happened and
it's like if you just type in Rachel
Ziegler's name it's like
every person who was born after between
like between like 1986 and like 1994 was
just like so pissed at her I've never
seen anything like it and meanwhile
Zoomers were kind of just like we
weren't going to see this movie anyway
there's an irony here too as Disney
tries to become more Progressive with
its live-action remakes that it actually
is overlooking some pretty fundamental
human rights questions so for example
there's a lot of push back to the film
Mulan because Disney decided to do some
of its filming in xinjiang in China
which is famously where the uyghur camps
are located and I think quite rightly a
lot of people said you know let's get
Back to Basics here human rights abuses
are taking place where you're filming
yeah absolutely I mean I don't think
Disney is like authentically woke or
Progressive or whatever you want to call
it I think that they are like how do we
get butts and seats in theaters right
and that's sort of the
um like more Sinister thing about it
like not only uh you know I saw I saw a
video where someone was like Walt Disney
would be rolling in his Brave and I
think it's he would be rolling in his
grave not only because these movies sort
of portray the original Spirit but
because it's like this mass-produced
it's an insult to the artists who who
clearly were very passionate about the
sort of the Original Stories right it's
to me it just it's like like it's almost
it's almost an insult to the word film
to call them film you know I think it's
very easy to go back and watch older TV
shows and films and find the flaws we've
seen this done with friends recently
we've seen it done with Monty Python and
now we're seeing it happen with Disney
and you can be almost certain that if
you do this you are going to find
problems you're going to find things
that would not be made today you're
going to find offensive and
inappropriate content that we would all
agree just simply would not be made now
and I would also add that for Disney it
went through a particularly Grim period
around Jim Crow where there was content
that you would simply not want to remake
today
and that strikes me as quite different
from what seems to be happening with
Snow White and what we're getting a
glimpse of which is that the storyline
is being rejected because it's based on
a premise that a love story is good
enough to base a film around as of the
concept of traditional romance is in and
of itself not especially feminist and I
wonder if this is this act of dismissing
true love uh completely as something
that just isn't worthy enough to to be
your film premise is actually a
disservice
um and I I question not wanting kids to
see that Keira Knightley made comments a
while back saying that she wouldn't want
her daughters to watch Disney films
anymore and and that strikes me as
um perhaps one of the strangest aspects
of all of this is that from the original
Beauty and the Beast to the original
Mulan to Meg and Hercules I think you
actually have some very strong quite
feminist characters it just wasn't so
explicitly laid out that way the
storyline itself uh you know the way
that the characters were written was
almost implicit but because it wasn't
being laid out on a platter saying look
at this you know this is a progressive
message people somehow take issue with
it I don't know I I prefer my story
lines for kids and for adults when
there's a bit more nuance
yeah I mean a lot of a lot of um Disney
movies actually really hold up a lot
better than people think like you
mentioned friends friends is a very
funny example because friends is one of
the only examples of this happening
where it like really didn't age well but
if you go back and watch uh like Beauty
and the Beast
um or Mulan like you mentioned uh it
it's it doesn't feel like you're not
cringing through it like it feels very
Timeless indeed well we'll just have to
wait and see what the new Snow White
holds in store Catherine thanks for
joining me
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
week
thank you
foreign